hell yeah hell yeah gutter Bracken is
here what's up man man you know man just
honored to be here Kev how you been
brother I'm good brother so tell me why
you well this your artist right here
right he's he's making noise in the city
yeah this my young [__] gutter Brack
and um he's out here doing his thing got
a project on the way just trying to come
you know start it off right shake some
hands kiss some babies let everybody
know who I'm [__] with right now and
we have a freestyle coming Yeah he
talking that [__] for sure for sure man
uh for people who don't know who you are
Rod obviously you've been a part
of Pusha for people who don't know push
Inc the label is kind of what introduced
the world to YG T doll sign you go on
and on right yeah so you've been a part
give me your history like cuz you've
been with Y from the the beginning yeah
you go back to any Y video I'm in every
every video I've been with bro since the
beginning I known him since we're like
12 years old right so you um like kind
of give me like like a a rundown of just
kind of like your history with him like
did it when when it comes to the music
industry yeah so like on the music
industry side I like to call myself a
professional homie um from the way that
I started off with YG because at the
beginning I was doing anything I was
answering phone calls I was passing out
flyers I was giving out mixtapes I was
driving to shows I'm driving across the
state to different shows whatever took
to my homies get to the next level
that's what I was on so I wouldn't call
myself like a day-to-day assistant or
assistant you were like a utility knife
professional whatever you need me to do
whatever you need you feel me got to
beat somebody up I'm there for that too
um yo it's crazy too because I think a
lot of people don't really like um
people know YG outside of La is just
like y he's been around for so long but
like the like early YG mixtape era was
like I I didn't live in LA at the time I
think at the time that was going on I
was living in
Vegas but I heard it was just like crazy
yeah that was a different era that was a
different time man we had these streets
at La really in a choke code and
honestly it was just about unity and
trying to bring people together we had
this park we used called push a Park
which is stalker park that's on like Le
and stalker and we just used to invite
everybody from the city up there to come
[__] with the pushers and it's like if
you up here and you [__] with us if
you got a issue with somebody y'all
going to handle that is this like kind
of like running simultaneously with the
jerk era or towards the end of the jerk
era you talking about um Ben J yeah I'm
know that guy no no no I'm not even
saying that I said the jerk era it was
an era of la music of course I'm saying
like cuz I feel like you guys kind of
like but I came like you know it's so
crazy because um a lot of the [__] I was
doing just just BJ catching as stray I
didn't even I didn't even say thez I
seen bro on Instagram talking [__] like
weeks ago and it's like bro I didn't
even know him I didn't know he was a
thing still he's not yeah wasn't he
[__] tanas n it was the other one
Legacy shout out Legacy yeah good for
him man was that the lightskin one yeah
yeah the lightskinn one was taking down
Tas yeah crazy because like for a while
Legacy like put new boy [__] on the back
burner to focus on tanas in her career
right before she took off it's like some
crazy St new boys were a wave for a sec
bro you go to [__] Legacy was a wave you
could go to Hot Topic and get a [__]
new shirt he was producing rapping he
was like they introduced him tight color
jeans to the world bro them things was
tight them tight jeans boy it was a
little different you know but no but so
like like the push ink [__] was like
bubbling I feel like at the tail end of
that and then you guys kind of took it
it was really all around the same time
like when I was in high school that's
like when jerking was cracking um and I
used to throw parties I used to do this
thing called club kids with like Twan
whis kid Casey and we used to throw like
these high school parties and had like 2
3,000 kids come weekend yeah we gave the
new boys is their first show Cali Swag
District their first show like a lot of
artist Audio Push had a a little way
going shout out to price shout out to
price that's the yeah yeah yeah so um
when did you guys realize that like what
you were doing was like actually
starting to kind of like you know work
bro I'll be lying to you don't realize
[__] is a movement until it's like
already start almost over almost exactly
you don't even realize you're living
through history until you look back back
you start sitting down talking about the
things y'all did and things like that
like damn we really just changed the
culture but we didn't even know what we
were doing change the culture we were
just trying to have fun and put out
music like like for a long time La was
like kind of like a No Man's Land a
little dead zone so it was like we
wanted people to respect what we were
talking about what we were bringing so
like in order to get the respect of the
world you got to get it in your backyard
first so like we made sure we had the
respect in LA to make sure we go to
these other places everybody championed
us